one little question started all of this
can Allah have a son if he wanted to
let's see if we can get some help man
you need you you need some help man let
no I don't but let me ask you a question
though you guys can jump in whenever you
want man so my question to you is if you
believe in an all powerful brother stop
stop stop brother just stop it how do
you claim brother stop just stop it I'm
G talk to him about this let's get back
to your topic brother his nature that's
the only answer God log let's talk about
your
topic it's not in his nature why why did
you guys tell uh hey he to stop talking
man he was he was making Headway who's
hey look man Mafia Viper why' you guys
tell okay okay so what you want to do is
you want to take the least knowledgeable
guy argue with him and say I prove that
hold on on
the speak Mafia Viper I'm G let you
speak my brother my brother hold on I
gotta defend myself by you saying I'm
not knowledgeable you you letting him
win at the end of the day man just
because somebody argu Mafia Mafia you
can't Pi SES you have to be logical the
truth the my brother you made a claim
you said I'm not as knowledgeable that's
what you said because you weren't able
to debunk him if you
were hold on my brother hold on I'm
holding on don't worry I'm holding on
this what you're doing man you letting
him win at the end of the day just
because he brother I'm not letting him
win he defeated you when you were not
able to answer
questions he doesn't know that truth he
is just smarter than you it's that
simple
brother he was smart you daily Quran I
think you know what's funny you know
what's funny you know what's funny I'm
here to talk to you want to argue with
me I'm not arguing with you my brother
sir logic can we get rid of the nuisance
my brother matter of fact on Sir logic
can we get rid of the nuisance on the
path on the path hold on I'm here for a
debate brother I'm not here to make you
feel good about your level of
intelligence brother my brother hold my
brother hold on let me I'm going just
say one sentence that's it go ahead go
ahead go go ahead so you going you going
to debate logic right yes sir when he
don't accept your reputation do that
mean you not acknowled U the difference
is that I didn't even accept the answers
you were giving him let alone him
accepted that's the difference brother
there were trash answers I'm going keep
it real 100% not your anwers thank you
see brother we're not trying to hate on
you we're not trying to
do not a good conversation with logic
was trash about my response though the
fact that you were not able to answer
what he was talking about
to just answer it's not in his nature
that's all I tell you what MAF I'll tell
you what M mute your mic listen maybe
you'll get it if you mute your mic and
listen maybe you'll understand what you
did wrong maybe I can't guarantee it but
maybe you will understand I said it's
not in his nature but because he
wouldn't accept it I just roll with it
no but the thing is you couldn't prove
how it's not in his nature you couldn't
prove it to him you as a matter of fact
you couldn't even prove it to me I
didn't even get what you were saying and
I'm a Muslim so let me talk to him
brother and just be quiet yeah but my
brother my brother that a how
Mafia you are literally in a debate with
me going against Christians yet you want
to argue with the Muslim brother that's
your that's your logic my brother I
ain't going against you what you don't
understand ISF Mafia conversation about
Quran and religion it's not a
conversation about Mafia Viper exactly
but you you so you need to calm down be
quiet keep your mic on mute and listen
to how the
conversation me okay so I'm going to
spend 20 minutes is arguing with another
Muslim when I should be talking to a
Christian on a topic that he brought up
right exactly that's what I'm do but you
started off the conversation by by by
giving a statement Against Me by by by
Sir logic nosense get rid of it please
yo Mafia just just chill out let him
talk talk Mafia this is a conversation
about with intellectual people try to
have a little bit of intellect when
you're going to get involved in
conversations I'm that's not you're not
being very helpful just be like just
just say nicely bro yeah will not listen
so if he's not going to listen I'm going
have to put him in his place in another
way my brother you're not going to put
me in my place yo Mia just just just
mute yourself you know let him let him
just talk see what he yeah but no hold
on at the end of who the hell you man
who the hell you at the end who are you
brother who the hell you you answer my
question who the hell youo I'm wait for
you as soon as you're ready you're not
representing good you're not
representing no he not representing good
you're both not representing good
exactly yeah he not represent I said
both of you chill out he came up on the
panel sideways anyway man both of you
just chill out you don't have to respond
like that calm down yeah you're getting
aggressive both of you just calm down
you getting aggressive you know don't
sit there and tell me don't sit there
and talk this who you're talking to
about religion this is who you're
talking to about religion sir logic next
time pick a better Target Target don't
pick any nuisance and then think you're
smart you see what you're picking on the
only nuisance only you see what you're
picking on a conversation the only
nuisance is you man you do you see what
you're having a call your brother in
Islam a man you know what's funny sir
logic is going to record this is going
to be like the Muslims who fault is that
who whose fault is that the fact that
you couldn't answer the question that is
whose fault is that did I call you a
nuisance or did you call me a nuisance
which one is Who's acting like one y yo
you calm down listen listen listen
listen listen you both to calm down just
say sorry to each other you know get on
with it it's not that hard okay Mafia
Viper I'm sorry are you sorry yeah I'm
good man go ahead thank you finally
about like 20 minutes but finally we
accomplished something in go ahead sorry
sorry so okay I do apologize for that
last remark I made sir logic We Ready
well it looks like you calm the Nuance
down huh so what you did on the P you
made yeah according to the Muslim
Brothers you a nuisance bro I mean it is
what it is you're a grown man so so the
Muslim Brothers this is how you guys
talk to each other that's all right with
me sure okay it's all right with me your
arguments is trash man okay thanks my
argument is trash so I'm not even
talking about you oh who you talking
about Maia just shut up please on the
P wait no no no drop BR don't don't drop
him who dropped him bro come on G come
on life sir logic do you hear Do you
hear that guy how that guy even speaks
let me hear Do you hear how he speaks do
you do you hear how he pronounces his
words brother you said my argument was
trash my brother your AR
your argument was argument come on
brother talk to me properly brother talk
to me properly are you serious yeah I am
serious brother talk to me properly if
you have talk properly brother
please you talk properly I've been
listen you talk properly not represent
us they do not I've been listening to
you the whole time you insult
Mees you me cuz I SLA you up in real
life I will slap you bro bro bro I'm in
Toronto bro who you talking to these two
do not represent us oh
man shut it
down out of the chat
bro you came to insult your brother in
can you guys both Shut Up N M I didn't
insult you m the on the path shut up on
the path shut up for a minute Mafia shut
up for a minute you guys do know what
you're doing right now it's on
right about how many prayers are in day
brother I don't even know if he's he
just voice on the shut up for a minute
you do understand what you're doing this
racism right now that's Haram that's a
yeah yeah exactly hold on hold let me
hold hold hold hold hold saying he's not
pronouncing his words properly is not
racist he's not pronounce he's talking
like ghetto how is that racist that's
that's literally racist R why is that
racist why can't you pronounce
why why talk on the shut up for a minute
you guys are you guys are in a live
representing Islam over in front of 898
people you this mafia guy wants to argue
with me because he doesn't understand
the point both of you both of you shut
up real quick you are representing Islam
up front of 900 oh dropped to 460 people
when back up to 898 in front of so many
people you guys are showing that you
you're being racist in front of that
many people a shame bro if you guys are
not going to be able to keep your cool
get the hell out of here yeah exactly
yeah I'm talking about
came I don't take ins lightly man I'm
talking about for both of you by the way
I'm not talking about
one this said man did you
have matter way speaks doesn't matter
different parts of America have
different accents they have different
different ways of speaking matter where
there you go okay then in that case I
should to be
saying because I'm in Toronto right on
the path on the come on bro have some
logic bro have some sense bro the guy
brother he cannot be a Muslim a proper
decent human being but he cannot
pronounce his words properly you're
being are you kidding me man on the path
that's L that on the path shut up are
you well get out this live because
you're
being understand Mafia Mafia please one
second on the path what you're saying
right now is is that's the worst thing
I've ever heard in bro I said the man is
not pronouncing his words properly that
has nothing to do that has nothing to do
with his background brother anybody who
wants to learn you what you saying you
going on 10 XP man slow down on the path
Mafia please this guy's yelling his head
off but he's telling me to slow down
Subhan Allah man Subhan Allah and then I
heard you ask the brother you said he
don't even know the five prayers you
trying to question my Islam man brother
add me you and I gonna have a one-on-one
conversation I don't need a oneon-one
with you man who the hell you okay so
stop talking and let me talk to siric
talk to me man I'm just saying who the
hell you okay we're done sir popcorn
let's go yeah you can put it down that's
okay you can put it down yeah yeah okay
so he said your arguments were trash so
uh sry sry sorry so logic I want to ask
you one question okay hold on a second
you just interrupted me I said two words
I know before you get the topic it's not
on the topic before you get top talk
while I'm talking please okay okay so he
said that your argument was trash and
it's because he's saying that you're not
addressing or really able to refute what
the verse is saying here that all that
what I'm saying
see and his reputation not what I'm
saying you see brother you said that his
his arguments is trash this is what I
was saying I was saying he he in the
same boat that I was in right he he
realizing that he thinks that I was
quote unquote losing but he failing to
realize I've been dealing with you Avery
me and you've been on live several times
I know how you
function but the brother here and my
brother I come at you with respect man
I'm telling you the way you came at me
you put me down thinking you going to do
better but you you you flopped man you
flopped brother out of the 15 minutes
I've been here my conversation has been
10 minutes with you and you're telling
me I flopped
I because I'll tell you what it is you
got the Arab superiority complex on me m
I'm not Arab brother I'm not Arab
whatever whatever you is I was the
racist right but you were racist okay
brother so sir logic quick question was
I being racist right now because I said
he couldn't pronounce his words what you
said I went to go get my popcorn but so
I didn't hear that's that's one way to
say no that's one way to say no but okay
let's get back on topic I didn't hear
what you said matter of fact matter of
fact logic can you put up a poll put up
a poll and ask the audience yeah what
did he come at me insult to me and was
his argument better than mine yeah sir
put up put up a poll for these 15 12
year olds of a child and then this is
hilarious have you been paying attention
you speak about this so let's set the
poll moderators put a poll up who did
better Mafia or on the paath who did
better thing not the better part but
okay and yeah who came at who came out
who sideways
first and also do the second poll did on
the path come at him come at Mafia
racist he have racial slurs or racial
comments so um do two polls who handled
the argument better on the path or Mafia
second poll did on the path come at
Mafia with uh you know with racism yes
or no and we'll see what the audience
says okay moderators get to work okay
here's the first one let's see what
happens here you know what's funny half
of the 90% of the people that's here
listening don't even know what's going
on and we're leaving the decision in
their hands that's the funny part all
right we have we have two intellectual
people here logic and King s but we're
going to leave the decision of whether I
was being racist or not into the hands
of 10 year olds 9 year olds 11 year olds
who are in the chat right now I see the
logic going on here well here where we
are ladies and gentlemen for those who
are just coming in we're arguing whether
all whether Allah is all powerful or not
my argument is is that he's not because
according to the Quran he can't have a
son by himself he needs a wife in order
to have a son meaning he's not all
powerful they're trying to combat that
so
where's where's the I don't know I
clicked it and they disappear moderators
can you guys put up the PO please was on
the path racist that's the first poll
and then two who handled the argument
better on the path or Mafia even though
I've been having the conversation for
like three minutes I think all you need
is three minutes you are 100% right to
prove myself against Mafia all I need is
three minutes you're not you're not
Muslim bro no muslim okay all right the
votes are coming in you guys got two
minutes all right we'll see what happens
when that vote ends sub Allah man Subhan
Allah this is this is why the isn't
isn't a disaster people like you man uh
Mafia let me ask you a question are you
a
I'm a sun man you're a sun right yeah I
would love to talk to you about theth in
your books brother I would love to about
that test your logic I want to test your
logic hold on hold on I'm brother that's
why you a bastard man expose I knew you
wasn't a Muslim hand Allah I knew you
wasn't a Muslim do you guys hear this do
you guys hear that do you guys you a
coward boy sir logic do you hear the
voice do you hear SP I SP your
do do you he hear how he pronoun you're
not Muslim don't claim Muslim boy do you
hear him his CL Muslim well you're the
Muslim right you should be more CL
Muslim boy sir logic you know what you
should do you should ask him about Abu
Bak should ask
about Muslim I swear to God I knew you w
no muslim man I could smell you you're
Allah you can you're Allah you know
everything right I slap you up in real
life Boy Logic you know what funny and
the and
in of
thew boy
why that guy
brother I'm tell you guys
something abak against against he went
against do you curse the prophet's wife
go ahead sorry what did you say all you
do is yell I didn't even know what you
said do you curse the prophet's wife go
ahead why would I curse the prophet's
wife you don't curse the prophet's wife
but I'm AIA right here's the thing
brother you think you're because AIA you
have your idea of who you think I am do
you no no no no no I what did I just say
what did I just say I just answer your
question what did I say you cursed The
Prophet's wife I answered that question
what did I say what was my answer I you
tell me answer no no you're listening
right what was my answer what was my
first answer and then I'll answer again
first what was my first answer I didn't
hear your answer I'm asku Cal down
here goofy listen and you'll hear I
don't curse none of the wife's prophets
none of them not even Aisha not noticed
you had to say that though yeah yeah
because I wanted to make sure that you
don't get lost in the conversation I
have to make sure that I Muslim brother
brother so 60 67% said you did have
racial comments against him man you okay
there you go get your she s out of here
I knew you brother that doesn't change
the fact of
how let me say one thing
this hold on do you guys hear how talk
hold on don't nobody give a damn about
your she s man at the end of the day
this this for the Muslim brother that
was on top of black doctor I'll give you
props I'll give you props for being able
to move the debate from being about
religion to De being about you I give
you props for that but keep
going keep going hold on hold on keep
going so the Muslim brother boy keep
going back boy hold on so at the end of
the day the Muslim brother on top of
black do notice how the Shia was easily
able to deceive the fellow Muslims so if
the brother the Muslim brother is still
in the comment section you were siding
with a Shia against your brother in
faith man you should be ashamed of
yourself man do you see your leers right
now bro all your are
sign you talking about all your leaders
are yeah bro all your Sunni leaders are
under Israel br isra yo if you don't go
down okay you know what sir logic is
okay with us having a conversation so
I'm going have a conversation with you
okay I want to have a conversation with
no you were talking to me you were
talking to me so let's talk let's talk
now okay okay let me ask you a question
who is under the rules of Israel right
now all the Muslim leaders tell
me all your leaders are under the pocket
of Israel you all your leaders all your
leaders all your leaders are in the
pockets of isra brother don't talk to me
keeping with you brother this guy's IMS
this guy's sh call let let's keep it m
up M up mute up let's keep it religious
Bas all right so you guys are fighting
each other and that was fun to watch but
but what did we expose he not Muslim so
come I need you guys to unite you gota
drop him man he not a Muslim he he he a
Muslim you know what's funny logic
because he doesn't like Amia he thinks
that you should drop me because I'm a
Shia he feels like he's Allah he knows
that Shia's are Muslim or not meanwhile
Muslim man she is ain't no muslim who
told you this your wait don't don't they
believe in one God Mafia she is ain't no
muslim ask him what we believe and then
ask the difference let me ask you this
uh Witnesses Christians no okay then
there you go how does that answer his
question there you that anwers the
question sir logic did that answer your
question no it didn't thank you yeah it
did yeah it did oh my God he certain
logic that did answer your question even
though cic is sing I don't even
understand what you're saying
L listen to me big you're not going to
call me on this chat
okay brother I'm aan together let's
let's keep it a mafia no no more brother
I'm aghan I'm not gonna let nobody call
me call I've been dealing with you and
your bro who you talking bro I'm not
Arab I'm an Afghan bro I've been dealing
with you there you go my logic you hear
yeah yeah bro you hear you pronounce the
words I don't even know why you got got
a racist on your P why don't y'all got
hey relax please thank you no more
inword ask question why me when I'm
talking bro so no more nword here no
more nword if you guys want to talk
trash y'all can talk trash but no more
nword okay all right so this is this is
this is the issue Jehovah's Witnesses
they don't believe what uh what we
believe they literally don't believe
Jesus as God you need to be Christian
believe Jesus Is God so on the path is a
Shia Muslim what about his beliefs
makes him not a Muslim do you pray hold
on how many times a day you pray go
ahead five times a day where you get
that from what do I get that from yeah
here's the funny part she has all pray
five times a day the only difference is
not all she has pray five times day man
you a liar man bro can I sir can I speak
yeah let let him let him answer see the
thing is these sunnis they're confused
about everything so they think they have
it figured out in Shia sect the prayer
goes like this it's five prayers but
sometimes the two afternoon prayers and
the two night prayers are prayed
together but because they're prayed
together even though it's the same
amount of prayers the sunnis like to say
that they only pray three times if they
actually listen if they count how many
raas they pray and how many raas we pray
it's the same exact amount so how are
you telling me that we pray the same
exact amount yet you're telling me I
don't pray five times a day you know
what rakat is Right Mafia Mafia do you
know what raak is or no why is he quiet
all of a sudden he's going to Google it
that's why
I'm wait don't worry you can Google I I
don't mind Google you can use Google let
me know what raaka means okay when
you're ready man we might need the
sunnis to speak up man I I ain't talking
to him I'm see now he's not talking to
me we went to the conversation to have
conversation with him now he's not
talking to I'm not addressing you I'm
not addressing you go ahead is this
logical logic is this logical to you
does that sound logical to you and the
CH want to say that he W the
conversation don't talk to the host
you're not talking to me brother you
want me to talk to you I'll talk to you
it's it's okay it's okay how many
records do you how many records do you
pray in a day all together he doesn't
want to talk he doesn't want to talk 17
17 how many do she no more inws hey hey
come on man how many do she has pray he
trying to clown but you see I'm asking
him a question no more inw not brother
how I'm not gonna talk to you man okay
okay okay I'll respect that you're not
gonna talk to me okay I'll respect that
all right so talk to me let's let's get
back on let's get back on track yeah
let's get back on track until he's ready
to talk to me again get back you guys
need to unite and join your arguments
against this one because this one is
irreputable I guess from both of
bro I will never ever Unite with
somebody who went against the family of
the Prophet did the the sunis went
against the family of the Prophet but
you guys you guys believe in the same He
Man y'all got y'all have a good one you
believe yeah he's done he's done he lost
he lost he's done he's done see how he
ran you see how he ran he brought up sh
as soon as I brought up how his people
I'm not I'm not gonna lie man he he he
brought up an argument and then he went
kind of quiet after that so that look
that didn't look good man that didn't
that didn't look good uh I agree so hold
on hold I want to ask a question about
the poll the Paul said that he did
better than me right in the debate right
they said that the Paul said he did
better than me in the debate but what
was the percent it was like 70 something
70 and 30 you see that so now let me ask
you does the pole know what they're
talking about or no because you seen
that what you seen what happened it's it
s it sound like they voted based on who
they liked better that's what it sound
they went they went based on feeling
rather than fact I don't think that yeah
let me see this really
his actions spoke louder than the chat
brother yeah I don't I don't I have to
disagree with this guys I don't think
that but I I don't think that Mafia I'm
sorry I don't think that I don't think
that un the pav did better than than he
did either so that's tough but they ask
who did better the fny part is he ran
away right on the Sunni and Shia part
yeah he he he ran away from that I got I
gotta admit that he did run away from
that he did run away from that so sir
logic my point here's my point okay
here's my point if he was actually smart
enough to be able to debate or argue
logically he wouldn't have lost that
little debate fair enough you know fair
enough but but the chats rather go with
feelings than facts right right that's
interesting that's interesting